hello
i'm mike sinckowski and today i'm going
to talk about
a new connection between node and edge
default graphs
this is joint work with jeremiah
lockheed
a difficult graph is a directed acyclic
graph
that has certain properties that we'll
define on the next slide
the reason we're interested in depth of
bus graphs
is they have many applications to
cryptography
um possibly the biggest application is
um depth bus graphs are used to create
secure
data independent memory hard functions
which are used for
password hashing additionally um there's
um death robust graphs have applications
to proofs of space and process
sequential work
um so to define different bus graphs
we'll first define a
maybe a simpler related notion we'll say
if
g is a directed acyclic graph
and we say g is e d node reducible
if there's some set of vertices of size
at most e such that when we remove all
those vertices
the depth of the remaining graph is less
than or equal to d
um and then we'll say that g is ed
node depth robust if it's not ed node
reducible
and so as an example we have this graph
here
and if we just say remove
node two then the depth of the graph
is three so we say that this
graph would be one comma three node
reducible
and node depth or bust would just be you
know not
no reduce one and similarly
or so traditionally when we say death
robustness without qualifying it
we mean no death robustness but um this
talk we'll be
um talking about both edge and no death
robustness so um
i will try to qualify it
um and so and now listen analystly we
can define
edge depth of bust graphs where here we
or edge reducible graphs where we just
remove a set of edges in this case
so instead we remove edges instead of
nodes
so here again we have this graph and we
can just remove the edge from one to two
and we see that if we remove one edge
then the
depth of the remaining graph would just
be four
so this graph would be one comma four
edge reducible
and um so it's the reason that we're
interested in comparing node and h f of
s graphs
is edge ether bus graphs are potentially
easier to construct than no death robust
graphs
if you think about just removing a
single edge from a graph
it doesn't affect it as much as say
removing a node
and then potentially removing all of the
edges incident to it um and so
for example we have two well-known
constructions of different bus graphs um
the erdishgram some radiograph
which is no difficult graph but it has a
very complicated construction and
analysis
on the other hand there's the the greats
construction
that is edge depth robust but has a
simple construction and a simple
analysis
and furthermore um many applications
require no depth of bus graphs in fact
all the
applications i mentioned earlier memory
hard functions process space etc
all require no development graphs so
we want to construct no depth of us
graphs but it's potentially
harder to construct them than edge depth
of those graphs
so the results from our research is
we um come up with a transformation that
transforms
an ed edge jumper bus graph that has
images
into an e over two comma d
node depth of this graph that has
constant integrity
and order m at order m notes
um and as a specific example if you
apply it to great the grades
construction we get a node depth of bus
graph that has
uh certain parameters here and um
no other known or no other construction
is known to achieve these specific
parameters
and uh later in the talk we'll get to
why these specific parameters are
important but uh
yes ours is the first known example of
these
that has these parameters additionally
to actually construct this
transformation we define
and then construct graphs that have a
new connective property that we call
st robustness um
these we'll get in in the talk we'll get
into
how we actually construct them but
these s-tier bus graphs also have
applications to
what we call perfectly tight proofs of
space and constructing
sources same depth of bus graph that
were used
for white block labeling functions
proposed by
chen and tezara
so first i'll go through the
transformation at a very high level so
we take a highly edge depth of bus graph
g and then we replace each node of g
with an str bus graph that has constant
integrity
has size proportional to the maximum of
the indegree and out degree of the known
and then the resulting graph the
transform graph
will have constant indegree and will be
highly node at the bus
so the question that we'll answer is you
know
what properties should this added st
robust graph have
so we can translate between edge up
robustness
and node depth robustness
so um just as a pictorial example say we
have a
part of some graph here and our
transformation would just replace
each of these nodes with a graph with an
ester bus graph
so the key building block what we call a
k1 k2
st or bus graph um so
the graph is a directed acyclic graph
that has
n inputs and outputs so here are the
inputs on the left side of this graph
and the outputs on the right side and
say we call it this graph
k1 comma k2 s2 bus if we can remove k1
nodes here in red
and there exists some sub graph
of g where that has at least k2 inputs
and k2 of the outputs such that
each input is connected to every single
output
so for each input there is a path
from it to all of the outputs these
paths don't have to be
node or edge disjoint or anything they
can overlap this has to the
each input node has to be re be able to
reach
all of the outputs
um so here as an example um we have this
graph
and we see that if we we can remove
any node like any one node in this graph
there'll always be some sub graph that
has two inputs and two outputs
such that each input connects to all of
the outputs
so we call it one two s two robust
um so now we'd like to construct is what
we call
maximally or maximal s to your bus graph
and we say that a directed acyclic graph
g is
maximally s to robust if it's
k comma n minus kst robust for all k
um basically we could potentially remove
an output or input node because we can
remove any of the nodes in the graph
so k comma n minus k is the best
possible
parameters and one of the main
contributions of our paper
is we prove theorem and reconstruct
a family of linear size constant and
degree
stir plus graphs and by linear size just
mean that uh there's
there's n inputs then there'd be
o n notes in the graph
so the core of our maximus tier bus
construction
um is consists of three
copies of a highly node depth robust
graph
that has constant in degree
that we call say h1 and h2n and h3n
and for each node in h3n
we pick say tah random parents in
h2n and taw is just a parameter that we
can adjust
um but it's a constant
so and again
for in h2 we pick
tall random parents in h1
so every node in h3
has some number of random parents in h2
and every node in h2
has some random number of random parents
in h1
and so we'd like to prove that say most
of the nodes
in h1 can reach
most of the nodes in h3
and so the way we do this is we fix some
set
of nodes i'm in the graph to remove
and then we know that each subgraph you
know h1 h2 and h3 is highly node depth
robust
and so um
from the exact parameters we can
um say find a long path in the graph and
then remove it
and since it's difficult then we can do
that multiple times
and find a number of node disjoint paths
so for example here on the right um say
maybe the
two graphs would be h2 and h3 then h2
has some number of
vertexes joint paths and h3 has some
number of vertex destroying paths
and we argue that say the upper half
of the paths and the left graph your
each
upper path in the left graph
connects to most of the lower paths and
the right graphs and by
lowering like the lower half so the
last half of the nodes
and we do that for both pairs so h1 and
h2
and then h2 and h3
and then after that we union bound over
all possible
s's and what we're proving is that
most of the um
paths in h1 um
connect to or can reach
most of the pads in h3
and finally we attach these graphs
called super concentrators
to h1 and h2 we don't really have time
to
go into and define another graph but
basically they just ensure
connectivity between all pairs of inputs
and outputs
in the you know final st or bus
construction
and uh further more just to note that
this
graph by itself um is not maximally st
robust um it is
k1 and k2 s2 bus for certain parameters
but we have another construction that
you can use to bootstrap
into a maximal ester bus graph but uh
just won't go into it here
and so um here is the
um formal um statement of our main
theorem
so if we have a um
a dag g the with m edges that is
e comedy edge diplo bust and we have a
family of maximally asteroids graphs
that have constant and degree
then the transformed graph g
prime will be e over two comma d depth
or bust
um we'll have max and degree is just the
max and degree of any of the s two bus
graphs
um and then
which would just be the um which would
be
constant if uh family of s two bus
graphs has constant in degree
and then we'll have a linear number of
nodes you just add up the number of
nodes
in each of the s2 or bus graphs
so the way we prove the main theorem is
basically by relying on the st
robustness property
so here we just we're looking at say one
node
in the graph that's been replaced by an
stereo bus graph
that has three incoming edges and two
edges
connected to the output nodes and so say
we remove
one node from this graph so
we're removing say one node from the st
or bus graph
then by the st robustness property we
know there's a subgraph that has two
input nodes
and two output nodes such that each
input node connects to
all the output nodes and
so what this corresponds to is
it's like we're removing two edges the
edges in red here it's like we're
removing these two edges from the
original graph
and that's because we can no longer
guarantee that the
each of the the input red edge connects
to all of the
outgoing edges
and so by this s to r business property
we see that we're moving a node
in our transform graph corresponds to
removing at most two edges in the
original graph
and that's the reason that our transform
graph is e
over two comma d instead of just e
because we lose potentially a lose two
edges
and so you know now that we see that uh
we can we lose at most two edges
if we take our transform graph and
remove a bunch of nodes
then that's equivalent to removing a
bunch of edges
from the original graph and since the
original graph which is just
was edge depth robust there will be some
path
through it and
then we can just transform that into a
path in the transform graph
because uh by the s t r business
property each of the input nodes
connects to all the output nodes so we
can just directly translate a path
in the edge from the original graph into
a path in the transform graph
as you can kind of see by this picture
and so um that's kind of a intuitive
high-level
overview of the proof of the main
theorem
so um sort of a guiding open question
for why we're interested in these um
there's a well-known memo called
valiance loma
that basically gives an upper bound on
the max
edge check robustness of any dag
so if you have a dag g with m edges and
end
nodes
um the net dag would be m times i
over log n comma n to the i
edge reducible for all integers from 1
to log n and the implication is
for the constant integrity graphs um
that we're generally interested in in
applications
that means that they're some order of
n times i over log n comma n over 2 to
the i
node reducible and so sort of a guiding
open
guide guiding open question is can we
construct
dags that match the bound for any given
eye
and so if we apply our transformation to
the grades construction then it gives us
a n times i over log n comma n over
log n to the i plus 1 no different bus
graph for all
i from 1 to log n and
this is an improvement for i that are
greater than 1 and less than log n um
for i
for i that are o order of one or order
of log n
there's already known constructions that
match it but uh this is an improvement
uh for the area in between those two um
specifically we're interested in
constructing a family of dags
that would match the bound uh for i
equals order of log log n
and the reason that is it would resolve
open questions
about the pebbling complexity of certain
um data independent memory heart
functions in fact it would uh
could be used to construct a maximally
memory hard data independent memory
heart functions
but uh so our reduction would give
n log log n over log n comma
n over log n to the one plus log log n
so it doesn't match the bound um because
there's an extra
log n to the log log n in the
denominator of d
but uh no other construction is known
to achieve these parameters specifically
for that e
on that high of d
and in addition to just constructing
depth of s graphs
um s t or bus graphs may be of
independent interest
because they have other applications so
for example
we can use an sd rust graph to construct
a perfectly tight proof of space
so here on the right we have a
construction
where we take a maximal s2 bus graph
mn and then overlay a different less
graph
over the inputs and then the
red nodes would be the target nodes so
in the
proof of space approver commits to store
labels
of n output nodes which would be the
target nodes colored red
in the picture
and in this case the uh we would uh use
a
maximal s t r bus graph that has n prime
[Music]
um inputs and outputs where n prime is o
of
m log n and then we overlay
on the inputs an n comma
order of m prime dr graph
and so the prover will commit to store
these labels that are
labels of the n output nodes and a
cheater will
say store less than n nodes so k for k
less than n
and um for each of the n minus k
challenges
that the cheater doesn't store if the
cheater is asked to produce that label
by the verifier
then the cheater would have to
re-pebble at least n prime minus k
inputs by the st robustness property
um and that would take at least
um so or omega and prime time
and so by type proof of space we mean
that uh
every challenge or every node that this
cheater doesn't store forces the cheater
to
um completely reap or forces
sorry any node that the cheater doesn't
store
um requires a lot of time the full
amount of
um omega and prime time to re-pebble
and uh finally um
our stir bus graphs are actually what we
call source to sink
depth of bust grass and what that means
is that we guarantee
that the path of length b starts at a
source node
and ends at a sync node um or starts at
one of the input nodes and ends at one
of the output nodes
and uh these were used in the cited
paper to
construct something called white block
labeling functions
and we won't get into the details but uh
our graphs
are asymptotic improvements on the
construction in their paper
so to summarize um we constructed
a new reduction that transforms edge
depth bus graphs
into node different bus graphs
and our reduction improves no different
bus constructions
for certain parameters
in order to create this transformation
we defined and constructed
s-tier bus graphs and these st robust
graphs
also have applications to proof of space
and just source to source to sync west
graphs
and uh here's the references um and
yeah that's it thank you for listening
you